[موسيقى]
خط القتال الفاصل بين الجيشين الروسي
والاوكراني يشهد تطورات ملحوظه بالمعنى
الميداني مع تسجيل تحرك لافت للجيش
الاوكراني تتركز هذه التطورات عند الجبهه
الشرقيه والجنوبيه الشرقيه قرب بخموت اعلن
الجيش الاوكراني ان وحدات سلاح الجو اسقطت
مروحيه روسيه واضاف ان مروحيه ثانيه
استهدفت واسقطت
مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني اندريارماك
علق بالقول امر رائع لكن من الافضل بكثير
حرمان روسيا من فرصه انتاجها فيما فهم
انها اشاره لتعزيز العقوبات على روسيا
لحرمان المشمع الصناعي العسكري من الوصول
الى التكنولوجيا بالانتقال الى دانيتسكت
تدخل بلده اوروجين وتارومايروسكي في قلب
المعارك تقول كياف انها تسيطر على اوروجين
بالكامل في وقت تقول فيه القوات المواليه
لروسيا ان القتال لا يزال مستمرا
نحن لا نتقدم فقط في اولجين بل ندمر
دفاعات العدو ونقلص من امكانياته القتاليه
لذلك لن نقيس النجاح بمقدار الكيلومترات
المحققه فقط ذلك ان مجرد التقدم في ظل
الظروف الحاليه يعتبر نجاحا كبيرا
في الشمال الشرقي كوبيانسك تحديدا تتضارب
الانباء حول ما يجري عند خطوط التماس
الجيش الاوكراني يقول انه صد محاولات تقدم
روسيه واوقع عشرات القتلى والجرحى في صفوف
القوات المهاجمه
تم بناء دفاع قوي للقوات الاوكرانيه في
اتجاه كوبيانس ومن الواضح ان هجمات العدو
اخده في الانخفاض حاليا فهم يعيدون تجميع
صفوفهم بسبب ضرباتنا ومقاومتنا القويه في
وقت تحدث فيه الجيش الروسي عن سيطره على
مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
اثناء القتال في اتجاه كوبيانس سيطره
المجموعات الهجوميه على معقلين وموقعين
للمراقبه واستهدفت وحدتي مشاه في منطقه
اولشان ومن اجل استعاده المواقع المفقوده
نفذ العدو خمس هجمات مضاده ضد مواقعنا تم
صدها جميعا
وسط هذه التطورات لا تزال المقاطعات
الحدوديه الروسيه عرضه بهجمات اوكرانيه
تقول روسيا انها اسقطت مسيره اوكرانيه فوق
مقاطعه بالجراد في استهداف متكرر منذ ايام